In today's healthcare environment
point-of-care begins with a touch.
iHeart Touch for the iPad explains
coronary artery disease to patients
using interactive simulations
and detailed medical animations.
In the exam room or home,
patients can take a self-guided tour
of coronary artery disease
learning how it progresses
silently over time.
At each step, patients can watch accurate,
award-winning animations
on treatment options
and view richly illustrated articles
all from Nucleus Medical Media.
The iHeart Touch app is an excellent tool
to use at the point-of-care
or at home to raise health literacy and
improve patient satisfaction.
Download iHeart touch today
free in the App Store.